hey everyone it's Mike from order here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about recognizing
strong orderflow in the market um but
before we jump in if you've been
enjoying learning from these videos
don't forget to subscribe and click the
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new uploads and if you find today's
video helpful be sure to hit the like
button for me and leave a comment
sharing your biggest takeaway I love
hearing your feedback your support
really does go a long way in helping me
create more uh videos just like this so
if you're getting value from my channel
and want to see more make sure you
subscribe and let's uh grow together now
let's go ahead and get started with
today's topic all right let's get into
it so understanding strong order flow
right I mean there's uh order flow in
the market you know always right Market
trades in a 2-way auction there's a bid
there's an offer but sometimes there is
just average order flow sometimes
there's weak order flow which you would
see in um you know a market that's sort
of going sideways you know sort of
directional list in the market drifting
um you know maybe the Market is waiting
for um you know a Fed speaker Powell to
speak or something like that or there's
a data release coming out but what about
during normal trading hours when there
is you know a trend underway what are
some of the ways that you can recognize
it and one of the ways that you can
recognize that is strong order flow and
what does strong order flow look like
well think about it
when you know when you're looking at the
order flow right on a footprint chart
you see you know the volume that was
traded on the bid the volume that was
traded on the offer okay and you're
going to see um when there's imbalances
in the market okay now imbalances are
when the volume in the bid or the offer
uh is greater than the other side by a
ratio of usually 4:1 some people like to
use 3:1 I like 4:1 I've always used 4:1
for um basically forever as long as I've
been trading with a footprint
chart
and the black numbers inside the bar are
just the normal orderflow so a red
number would be a selling imbalance a
blue number would be a buying imbalance
and the black numberers just your normal
order flow that's taking place in the
two-way auction okay so one of the
things that you want to look for on a
strong uh you know on a trending day or
a day that exhibits strong order flow
now let me just preface this strong
order flow doesn't necessarily mean
heavy volume volume it's how the volume
is coming in and being traded is what
you're going to uh Define as strong
order flow okay so you know today just
recently we made a high up here around
9:30 uh we sort of pulled back a bit but
let's take a look at earlier because we
opened up during the cast session right
near our highs and started making new
highs um you know we got all the way up
to 49 99 and a quarter just uh right on
the cash open then we pulled back okay
we pulled back from from 99 and A4 down
to 89 so it's about 10-point pullback
and then looked like we're going to take
off then we pulled back more made let's
say a swing low but we got down to 88
and then it took off above 5,000 and
much higher all the way up to 15 and a
quarter here so um basically we took out
this high at 99 a half 99 and a quarter
we Rose another 15 points okay and said
right now we're not that far off we're
trading around uh 511 right now our high
is 15 and a quarter so we're about four
points off that high we'll see what L
happens later but what is some of the
signs of strong order flow okay so we
hit that high we pull back it's
understandable okay we hit a high on the
cash open we pull back um you know maybe
there was some profit taking but once it
started bottoming out down here between
846 and and uh 8857 right we're sort of
going sideways you have a nice stacked
buying IM balance on the way up nice
stack selling balance on the way down
and then it sort of reverses and it's
Off to the Races here right basically
from 4990 all the way up to you know
above 5,000 okay so you know on the
first pullback we had this nice stack
buy imbalance right it's actually five
levels 1 2 3 4 5 you know 52 66 76 244
388 you know that's a sign of
potentially you know hey you know
there's aggressive buyers coming in on
this pullback which is you know
something that you want to see on a
pullback you want to see the market if
the market is pulling back and you're
going to look for the market to go
higher you're going to want to see some
aggressive buyers step in to to sort of
recognize that hey these prices are
attractive okay and yeah we go higher
you know we get only up to 96 and a half
we got this little double top and then
we pull back down below this stack
buying a balance below this low that was
just made here at 8 and a half got down
to 88 and then we start our I say start
our run up yet but we sort of go up a
little bit and then pull back and then
take off but after we hit 96 and a half
we start coming off okay we got a stack
selling a balance now the volumes
involved in the selling balance even
though it's a stack sound balance what
are the volumes 67 against two 72
against 1 128 against
one okay it is technically a stack sell
and a balance because it's three
imbalance a stack neatly on top of each
other
but would I consider this a strong
selling imbalance well not really
because the volumes in here are kind of
light okay at least here yeah you had 52
66 76 but up here is 244 388 here the
biggest one is just is just 128 now if
this 285 was an imbalance in 344 I'd
probably look at it a little bit
differently but it wasn't okay so Market
sells off a little bit gets a little bit
of a push pulls back up towards this um
Step back selling a balance then comes
off and then it starts taking off
now what is interesting on this move up
towards this High here okay so again
buying it here early on this uh first
deck buying a balance again not
necessarily a bad
idea you know but you know when you see
that stack cell of balance come in yeah
maybe it's time to you just cut it I I
not sure I'd be looking to uh all of a
sudden get short and look for a move
down to the low yet cuz it just the
intensity of that imbalance stacked
imbalance is just not enough for me I I
like it to be a bit stronger in terms of
volume and then the market just goes
sideways then it starts reasserting
itself here the aggressive buying how
how do I know the aggressive bind is
reasserting itself well just by looking
at the the Deltas 400 900 700 okay so I
know it's um pretty strong or it's not
pretty strong but getting stronger even
though this bar has got 137 the 406 982
780 is strong here we got a decent stack
buying balance 263 99 140 people going
say well it's only 99 it's not 100 okay
it's one contract less than 100 um you
know I I would take that as being pretty
strong so they're all above three digits
but again maybe not convinced yet okay
we got a nice stack sorry got a nice
stack buying and balance in this bar got
a nice Delta in this bar
982 got a nice um Delta into volume of
34% so it's telling you the Delta as a
percentage of the volume is 34% which is
a nice strong that's why it's colored
cyan you got this imbalance up here okay
so it's telling you that you know it's
145 against 12 yeah there there was some
bidding taking place in the market okay
then what happens in the next bar it
starts trading a little bit higher and
Delta's 137 it's not super strong but
we're closing on our Max Delta
okay then this next bar we got two
buying imbalances they're not stacked on
top of each other you know when you're
looking at imbalances it's easy to see
stacked imbalances right whether stacked
buying imbalances or stack selling
imbalances simply because they're
stacked neatly on top of each other but
when you start running into bars that
have multiple imbalances two or more to
me that's also an important sign right
it's telling you that there's aggressive
binds just not coming in Bunch sort of
uh you know a couple prices right it's
being spread out then the next bar same
thing two buying imbalances now to me
what really stood out in these bars
again our high for the day is 99 and a
quarter we're trading about four points
off here at uh you know at 95 but even
earlier here okay volume in this bar
honestly is pretty evenly distributed
right you got a Delta of 137 so this is
telling you aggressive buyers were
slightly in control but look at this bar
here okay what do you got you got a very
strong positive Delta
780 so you know aggressive buyers are in
control aggressive buyers are in control
and they're pretty
strong then when you sort of expand it
out a little bit take a closer look
insect the
volumes you can see there's heavy
volumes also on the bid
side and what's interesting is you know
406 is your heaviest volume on the bid
side
in this bar or actually the heaviest
volume either on the bid or or you got
49 here but it's the second highest
volume
406 cuz imagine right it's 780 Delta
you're going to be thinking that the
volumes are going to be kind of thin on
the bid side just like here
982 the volume right the heaviest volume
is only 277 next one's only 151 but on
the offer side it's pretty consistent
193 358
but over here you're getting strong
volume up near the top of the bars the
305 the 406 224 317 so it's happening
Market's getting bid up you know people
are lifting the offers but then it's
becoming bid here at higher prices for a
heavier
volume then in the next bar it's kind of
a small bar again Delta of 149 still
positive two buying imbalances this one
where's the heaviest volume it's on the
bid side 58
three next bar again two buying IM
balances where's the heaviest volume
coming in it's on the bid side
799 so I know I just by looking at the
volumes over several bars one two three
well these two bars at a minimum the
heaviest volume is on the bid side still
got positive Delta so it's telling me
that there are strong bids in the market
here
and then next bar again nice positive
Delta 401 just one
imbalance then the next bar we pop up
above 5,000 you got nice stacked buying
and balance in there and look at this
heaviest volume taking place in this bar
is where right here
51 spot 5 1415 the heaviest volume is on
the bid
side so I know there was biders coming
in here at 1 and a half biders coming in
here at 98 biders coming in at um 972
even here
952 I know there's strong bidding taking
place in the market and that that's why
I talk about strong flow that is a sign
of what strong flow is right it's not
just aggressive buying taking place in
the market right because yeah you need
that right that's what's going to move
the market higher people lifting the
offer and going for the next offer but
what's holding the market from going
down is people bidding and bidding
strong volumes right it doesn't
necessarily have to be the heaviest
volume in the bar but it should be
relative to the volume in the bar right
even though this um you know 406 isn't
the heaviest volume it's the second
heaviest volume to the 489 up
here right here's your heaviest volume
583 against 541 up here 799 against only
571 you know 794 is not your heaviest
the heaviest was 890 but it's still a
very strong number it's not 294 it's 794
obviously up here is, 1415 versus
heaviest volume is what 1073 so you know
right that you're
seeing strong bids in the market and
often times these strong bids are going
to be you know those long-term Traders
the other time frame Traders what's
interesting about this 1415 coming in
here is it's coming in at new high l
levels if it's coming in at new high
levels do you think those are um
intraday Traders no it's probably other
time frame Traders you know people with
the Deep Pockets thinking you know
I got to get in I got to lock in a
position on this because we're probably
going higher right and we got all the
way up we moved all the way up you know
to here to 15 and a quarter starting to
come off a little bit right now again
we're still trading around
08 but we'll see I mean in the grand
scheme of things I mean obviously 5,000
is a big psychological level in the snps
um you know chances are I
think again it's an election year it
benefits uh the current Administration
to keep the market uh propped up I don't
know I I Le read a lot of bearish
information in the market um in terms of
data with consumer spending and all that
stuff um you know we we'll see what
happens with this Market eventually but
but for right now recognizing strong
order flow you're watching how the
volume is being distributed throughout
the
bar okay as the market is going up same
thing you what I just said if you were
to turn it on his
head 180 degrees that would be um the
same thing would apply if the market
were selling off again you know I can't
talk about a market selling off cuz
we're at uh highs up here um but anyway
I hope you guys you know understand how
recognize strong orderflow it's not just
the aggressive buying you need strong um
bidding on a market moving up if the
market was moving down you would need
obviously aggressive selling which would
be evident through uh selling and
balances stack selling AB balances
negative Delta but then you're going to
want to see Supply coming into the
market in the form of big offers to keep
the market from going up okay so all
right guys so if that wraps up today's
video on strong volume or strong order
flow rather so if you found these tips
today helpful for your understanding of
order flow let me know what You' like to
discuss next by leaving a comment down
below if you enjoyed this video make
sure to hit that like button and
subscribe to my channel so you don't
miss any more of my upcoming videos all
right so thanks so much for watching and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye-bye